hey 42 here
last year i did what i consider to be
the greatest accomplishment of my life
i published my first book stick a flag
in it
i naturally expected to see it in the
bargain bin at my local bookstore within
the first two weeks but actually
the response was amazing
i set out to make british history more
accessible and hopefully just a little
bit more fun and now i want to do the
very same thing and more for another
period of history that has captured my
curiosity my entire life
ancient rome
introducing bread and circuses what did
the romans ever do for us
a book that i'm absolutely loving
writing and i can't wait to share with
you i want to tell you all about the
secret lifestyle of gladiators that you
won't learn from russell crowe i want to
tell you about the series of roman
emperors who were endlessly intriguing
and as batshit crazy as crazy's come
from the emperor who spent his entire
reign hunting down the largest penis in
rome
to the emperor who killed 100 lions in a
single day in close combat i want to
show you how the life of a roman citizen
was remarkably similar to your own with
fast food shopping malls and celebrities
but i also want to reveal the ways in
which romans were worlds apart from you
and me but most importantly i want to
show how in a way you maybe have never
realized before
the world as we know it wouldn't be
without the romans through a unique
blend of good bad and occasional genius
ancient rome hammered out the rules
regimes and recipes that forged the past
two millenniums of our history
all the way to the modern day
like sticker flag in it bread and
circuses will take you down the less
well trodden road of history i won't
bore you with lengthy lecturing but i'll
aim to bring history to life in a way
that you were never taught in school and
in a way that i hope will stay with you
for the rest of your life
i want more than anything for you to
join me on this journey of discovery but
i really need your help to make it
happen
i'm working with the amazing publisher
unbound once again to crowdfund this
book
every person who pledges to make this
book a reality will have their name
printed in the book forever
so if you support this book and make it
possible you'll get an early access
first edition hardback copy as soon as
it's printed with your name in it and if
you pledge slightly more you can also
get a signed copy and a limited edition
bread and circus's mug i realize that by
pre-ordering my second book you're
putting a lot of trust in me
and if that's what you decide to do then
i want to say thank you in advance
thank you so much
and in return i promise to put as much
energy as i humanly can into making this
the best goddamn roman history book on
the whole freaking planet i want it to
be bigger better more interesting and
funnier than sticker flag in it and
ultimately i want to show you that i
don't take that trust for granted so
thank you again and be sure to follow
the link in the description to go to
unbound.com
to pledge your support to this project
and lock in your signed copy of bread
and circuses what did the romans ever do
for us so you don't miss out
thank you